China the country that is not the thing
you fill a cabinet with when you've run
out of human needs I know there is a lot
going on with China right now from the
ongoing pro-democracy protests in Hong
Kong to the trade war that's been good
and easy to win for the last year and a
half now but this week China took a
moment to celebrate the 70th anniversary
of the Communist Party coming to power
and they did it in some style Chinese
President Xi Jinping and other senior
officials watched a ground evening gala
Tuesday on tenman square a song called I
love you China played and the number 70
was formed in the night sky oh they
didn't just make a 70 out of fireworks
people also made a 70 out of chickens
and out of pandas although I will point
out that is actually just a seven made
out of pandas with a zero made out of
apples and honestly if there aren't
enough pandas to make a whole seventy
out of pandas maybe pandas don't deserve
to be made into a 70 you might not like
it when I employ pandas a shitty and
worthless but you know who agrees with
me on that other pandas pandas look at
pandas and say that thing sucks so much
I would not it if the survival of
my species depended on it which it
absolutely does but that's not the point
the point is since China's government's
in celebrating its last 70 years we
thought we'd help tonight by
highlighting one of the most massively
consequential policies they undertook in
that time the one-child policy it began
in 1980 and it was basically exactly
what it sounded like upon a policy from
the government limiting how many
children families could have and I know
it might seem like old news but this
policy actually ended far more recently
than you might think an historic
decision in China the Communist Party is
ending that country's one-child policy
as a method of population control that
was 2015 meaning China made the historic
decision to end its one-child policy the
same year Pizza rat made the historic
decision to carry Pizza downstairs while
being
right now which one of both decisions
will prove to be more historic we won't
know until future generations are
reading about both events in their
history textbook history is memes now
435 pages about Pizza rat so why talk
about something that's now over well for
one thing the history of the one child
policy reveals a lot about how the
Communist Party has used and held on to
its power and for another the effects of
it are far from over
in fact the one-child policy is behind a
lot of challenges facing China right now
to take just one major example for
reasons we'll discuss later there are
currently around 34 million more males
than females in China that is a lot in
some villages the ratio of men to women
can be nearly two to one it's a
situation that's made some journalists
who visited noticeably sad welcome to
the most miserable place in China for
lovers here where single men sit around
all day it seems with nothing to do you
come across them everywhere listless and
hopeless so the most miserable place in
China for lovers are presumed narrowly
beating out wherever they keep the
pandas the one on the right is clearly
thinking oh I am not doing it and the
one on the left is completely fine with
that so tonight let's talk about China's
one-child policy why it happened how it
was carried out and what the
consequences have been and let's start
with why it happened in the 60s and 70s
overpopulation was a huge global concern
with alarmists making apocalyptic
predictions even Disney got in on it
producing this video for the population
council suppose that in time more and
more children are born the children will
be sickly and
with little hope for the future this
picture can be true for countless
families if the number of children born
has left to chance but fortunately this
need not happen anymore modern science
has given us HC that makes possible a
new kind of personal freedom family
planning family planning okay so first I
know I know that clip seems a little
racially problematic but but let's
remember Disney also made song at the
South so we're grading them on a very
steep curve here but secondly and I
cannot stress this enough I don't care
how useful the information Donald has on
family planning might be you never take
advice on having sex from a duck they
have corkscrew-shaped penises that they
regrow every mating season so Donald
Duck actually looks like this and I'm
simply not family planning lessons from
some corkscrew dicks pervert in any case
curly dick duck aside the overpopulation
hysteria was global and China was no
exception and the Communist Party also
saw controlling their population growth
as key to raising the country's economic
prospects and standard of living making
it easy for them to hold on to power so
who did they pick to solve this issue
well just take a minute and think about
who would be the absolute worst choice
to craft a prescriptive nationwide
policy on reproduction do keep in mind
Jared Kushner is not Chinese it was
actually the military the policy was
crafted by military scientists which is
one expert will tell you was not ideal
it was conceived by men right so and
these men were primarily missile
scientists you know who envisioned women
as you know in some ways like machines
what these men thought were that woman's
fertility you can push it up or push it
down like a switch they didn't
understand that that's not how things
work yeah she's absolutely right family
planning isn't rocket science and that's
exactly why rocket scientists should not
do it
it's the same reason we don't let OBGYNs
launch babies into space and land them
on the moon experts should stay in their
Lane now this policy was a nationwide
directive in the form of an open letter
to members of the Communist Party but it
was actually implemented at the lower
level meaning enforcement varied wildly
depending on where you lived so there
could be exceptions many rural areas
even allowed families a second child if
their first was a girl but the general
message was to have just one child and
it was often expressed through striking
propaganda like this undeniably
effective I can think of no better way
to dissuade parents from having more
children than by showing them that
particular child congratulations mrs.
Jang you've given birth to a real a grow
little narc
there were also propaganda signs saying
things like respond actively to the call
that each couple should have only one
child and have fewer children but raise
the quality which is just not how
children work children and I say this as
a loving parent are not high quality
individuals their artwork is derivative
and their story's meandering no one has
ever been asked who's your ideal dinner
guest has said someone who insists their
food be dinosaur-shaped but broadly the
one-child policy was also enforced by an
enormous bureaucracy at the national
level alone there were half a million
employees in charge of administering it
with many many millions more at the
local level and their scrutiny could be
pretty intense workers must have their
factories permission to get married each
team of 16 women has its birth planning
worker she is constantly alert for
anyone who might be pregnant or even
thinking of having a child we
asked doesn't the fact that she's always
watching her workmates always asking
them about their periods and so on
doesn't that make for resentment no the
workers are grateful for my concern
really are you sure about that the
workers are grateful for your concern if
there is anything I know about women and
there definitely isn't it's that they
love to be ask detailed questions about
their periods at work seriously just go
up to a caller you can say how do you
like that diva cup girlfriend to wear
with the period thong to prevent leakage
and how about that new extra absorbent
period toilet paper my female writers
told me that one of those things I just
said isn't real but they refused to tell
me which one is on beaver cup because it
sounds like what Mariah Carey demands
all her beverages come in I could be
wrong but but obviously the enforcement
went much further than that
local officials would issue massive
fines for having more children than you
were allowed Phi's the world routinely
multiple times a house holds annual
income many villages actually came to
depend upon those fines for revenue and
even if parents could afford them some
chose never to let their kids ever
forget it one child policy fines are now
so common that they're being
incorporated into children's names now
why did we name our child 20,000 chen
because that's how much we were fine to
have him 20,000 un yeah they named their
kid 20,000 chen so everyone would know
what they had to go through to have him
it's the equivalent of naming your child
Jason last minute epidural and a whole
lot of on the table Rabinowitz
it's a lot to make that kid carry around
and massive fines were clearly far from
the worst-case scenario here
particularly for girls because in China
there's traditionally a very strong
preference for boys which are seen as in
a very real sense and economic
investment for old age as sons are
expected to support their parents so
families would go to great lengths to
make sure that their one child was a boy
from abandoning girls to having sex
selective abortions two cases of female
infanticide and in some areas the
government's methods of preventing
all births regardless of gender were
absolutely brutal children could be
taken and sold to orphanages and there
were millions of forced sterilizations
and forced abortions this woman is still
haunted by the fact that she was forced
to abort her child at nine months
because her husband had a child from a
previous marriage
I saw one look that's obviously
horrifying and I know that there are
some who like to hold up China as a
blanket argument against abortion in
general so just let me be clear on this
it is very easy to be both pro-choice
and anti forced abortion in the same way
that you can be pro drinking fountain
and anti waterboarding the important
thing really is who's in control of the
process so so as you have seen
as you have seen so far many
heartbreaking decisions were forced on
Chinese families by the one-child policy
and at this point I'm sure you'll be
relieved to hear that we're gonna jump
now from the past to the present because
there are enormous ongoing ramifications
to China's policy and much like Donald
Duck's penis there are a lot of twists
and turns and an important point at the
end because for a government that made
it a point to micromanage their citizens
lives China did surprisingly little to
prepare for the long term consequences
of this policy and let's start
relatively small here the one-child
policy meant that an entire generation
is filled with many many only children
and some theorize that that means lots
of kids whose parents have overindulged
them as a newscast explained in the 90s
in a not very tactful way a surprising
byproduct of China's affluence is a
young generation with growing numbers of
fat children's little Emperor's or
little meatballs as they're sometimes
called
knew what pulling that kid a little
meatball is both mean and adorable
because on one hand you shouldn't call a
child a meatball if he doesn't want to
be called a meatball but on the other
hand look at that little meatball look
at this little meatball hats all about
that little meatballs tell me I want a
boy just tell me I don't want to say not
not and they don't want to throw it up
in the air and say who's a little
meatball you are you are that's the only
proper reaction to that little meatball
hashtag meatball hero
hashtag data spicy meat-a-ball but when
the one-child policy didn't just produce
lots of scrumptious little meatballs
remember those finds that resulted in
twenty thousand chen obviously there
were many parents who did not have that
kind of money but even if for whatever
reason they were somehow able to keep
their child there was a massive catch as
this woman born 26 years ago as a second
child can attest officials told her
parents they would have to pay a fine
the equivalent to about four years of
their salaries they could never afford
it
so she was never registered as a Chinese
citizen to this day her birth
certificate has a blank instead of her
name without an ID card she says I can't
have a normal life I could never go to
school never see a doctor I can't work
and I can't get married it makes me very
sad exactly she can't go to the doctor
find a job or get married she's
essentially a ghost without all the fun
parts of being a ghost like rattling
chains or summoning cold winds or making
terrible ceramics while having sex with
DES me more and the thing is that woman
is far from alone by one estimate at
least six and a half million Chinese
have no official status because they
were born outside the family planning
rules but one of the largest and perhaps
most far-reaching effects of a policy
that resulted in the elimination of
millions of girls is that a couple of
decades later you have a generation with
a massive gender disparity and far more
men than women 34 million more you may
remember and the reality is that
millions of Chinese men will end up
without female mates which is created a
number
odd business opportunities to give men
an edge in attracting women this is an
agency catering for China's growing
population of singles choosing the right
clothes
choosing the right chat-up lines on the
first date are all part of the plan for
singles like local Shang newfound magic
skills may do the trick you can really
impress a girl he says and magically
they'll become attracted without even
knowing it now now I know this might
seem hard to believe and that's actually
a pretty amazing magic trick there it
works like this at the beginning the
hoop and the chain are separate and by
the end any woman he's talking to has
disappeared no matter how many cool cool
tricks they learn the fact is millions
of men who want a wife will never have
one which has led to a bunch of
unintended consequences including the
success of this company there are far
too many men in China compared to the
number of women it's a great business
opportunity there are more and more
single men who cannot find a wife and
are desperate so we've decided to make
life-size dolls for them these men are
happy to pay the price because the
alternative is to be alone for the rest
of their lives ok
just for the record buying a life-sized
sex doll does not stop you from being
alone in fact it makes you somehow more
alone than you were when you were
totally alone if one is the loneliest
number one and a sex doll is the even
loneliest a number and while buying a
sex doll to replace the wife you'll
never have may seem like rock-bottom it
turns out it's actually somewhere around
ROC middle because the gender imbalance
created by the one-child policy has
created a huge market for human
trafficking with women and girls
trafficked from within China or
surrounding countries to be sold as
wives for Chinese men in fact one study
estimated that in just a four year
period
21,000 women and girls just from
northern Myanmar were forced into
marriage in one Chinese province alone
and look
maybe isn't fair to expect the rocket
scientist who designed this policy to
anticipate the boom times it would
create for sex dolls and human
trafficking but the irony is that one of
the key justifications for the policy
was that it would boost China's future
economic prospects and those prospects
and now under threat
thanks to that very policy China's
population is now rapidly aging and the
youngest generation is facing some
crushing responsibilities researchers
estimate that by 2025 one in five
Chinese and urban areas will be over 60
and that by 2050 that age group will
increase to 30% of the population the
policy has led to what is called the
four to one problem where one child will
be responsible for two parents and four
grandparents right that's a lot for
someone to take on and if you've seen
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
you know the pressure of having four
grandparents all relying on you means
your best-case scenario you win a
chocolate contest and you end up
impressing a slave owner by surviving
his child murder Factory but that's only
gonna happen to what 12 14 of them tops
the rest are facing a big challenge here
there are there are worrying science for
China from 2012 to 2017 the country's
working age population decreased by 25
million people which is the equivalent
of the entire population of Australia
disappearing from the workforce and not
for the reasons Australians usually
leave the workforce like being carried
off by a giant snake Australia is their
terrible Island full of monsters I'll
prove it to you those aren't even stars
on their flag they're spiders shoot get
out of here get out of here you're
disgusting
and the troubling economic forecast is a
big reason why China's government
decided to end their one-child policy of
thinking well great happy ending that's
it then
the government learned it's lesson and
stopped meddling with family size not
exactly because remember that clip that
I showed you earlier announcing that the
policy was over let me play out just a
little bit the Communist Party is ending
that country's one-child policy as a
method of population control all China
couples will now be allowed to have two
children exactly the one-child policy is
over but a two-child policy has now
begun so Chinese couples can do whatever
they want as long as what they want is
having two children like the government
wants them to want but the thing is many
couples don't actually want that China's
birth rate has fallen to its lowest ever
despite the policy shifts due in part to
rising living standards and the cost of
having children and in response to that
the Chinese government is pushing the
appeal of two children hard in ways that
may by now seem a little familiar to you
because there's propaganda once again
they've released stamps showing a happy
monkey with two babies there are signs
that say things like one is too few two
is just right the young will have
siblings the old will be cared for and
there a government produced PSAs like
this all our friends of childbearing age
are you aware that the comprehensive
two-child policy officially went into
effect on January 1st 2016 the reform
and improvement of family planning
services will be a great thing for not
only each individual family but also the
great family that makes up China look Oh
grant that was a very compelling
argument made by a very very sexy
cartoon we all agree on that right
that's a hot tune right there but when
you consider well yes now you get don't
you see we couldn't be basically a
copyright infringement but when you
consider all the one-child propaganda
that came before that that's actually
pretty jarring to watch I haven't seen a
messaging turn around that abrupt since
subway changed their slogan from eat
fresh to forget that pedophile
it was direct you have to give it to
them and once again enforcement of the
to child policy is being left to local
officials so methods for carrying it out
can still vary widely that there are
concerns that the low birth rate is
behind a push in some provinces to
tighten access to abortion and make it
more difficult to get divorced and in
other areas where too is being treated
as a hard limit people exceeding those
limits are once again frightened of the
worst consequences just
this man whose wife got pregnant with
their third child he was so terrified
he'd only talk with his identity
disguised a third baby is not allowed so
we went into hiding family planning
officers conduct pregnancy tests every
three months if we were not in hiding
they would have done a forced abortion
and that right there does suggest the
Chinese government still hasn't learned
the fundamental lesson here people are
not machines whose reproductive systems
can be turned on or off at will and
pretending otherwise leads to all the
consequences that you've seen tonight
from the entirely foreseeable like
trauma and heartbreak to the less
anticipated ones like delicious little
meatballs desperate magic tricks and a
factory that can't pump out sex dolls
fast enough and actually that image is
pretty on the nose if you think about it
a factory churning out headless silicone
women because rocket scientists nearly
40 years ago didn't care enough about
what their policies might do to real
ones so as China's Communist Party this
week nostalgically celebrates its 70
years in power it seems worth
remembering a massive way that they use
that power and if they are running low
on pandas which they clearly are I'd
argue that sex dolls might actually be a
more appropriate tribute they've
certainly got enough of them so happy
70th - the Chinese government
you